supongamos que tenemos la misma
trayectoria que teníamos en el vídeo
pasado aquí dibujo el eje y por acá
dibujo el eje x y nuestra trayectoria
anterior se veía más o menos así la voy
a dibujar algo como de este estilo me
está quedando un poquito diferente en
realidad si regresamos al vídeo anterior
nos debería quedar algo como de este
estilo pero bueno me quedo muy parecida
verdad la idea es que en el fondo es la
misma curva que la del vídeo anterior
pero bueno antes teníamos un campo
vectorial en el cual todos los vectores
eran múltiplos del vector y en este
vídeo vamos a ver otro campo vectorial
pero ahora el chiste es que todos sus
vectores van a ser múltiplos del vector
j es decir son vectores verticales vamos
a llamar este campo vectorial q de xy
iguala con mayúscula de xy multiplicada
por el vector unitario j ok siguiendo la
idea del vídeo pasado nos interesa
evaluar la integral de línea la integral
de línea en la trayectoria cerrada c
de cv a ver voy a ponerlo así con otro
color de q
punto de r como ya lo dijimos
anteriormente de r lo podemos poner así
de re es igual a de x por y más de g por
j con esto podemos continuar resolviendo
la integral ponemos por aquí la integral
de línea a ver a iván voy a poner la
integral de línea sobre la curva cerrada
hace ahora q solo tiene componente j
entonces al hacer el producto con de r
solo nos va a importar el sumando que
tiene j esto se debe a que y punto j es
0 entonces voy a poner aquí abajo lo que
nos queda
nos queda q a ver lo voy a poner con el
color blanco q de x
x de g
entonces una vez más como no había ahí
en el producto punto perdimos el de x
ahora veamos si existe alguna forma de
evaluar esta integral sin tener que
pasar por el parámetro adicional t justo
como lo hicimos en el vídeo pasado de
hecho todo lo que vamos a hacer es
idéntico pero intercambiando las x es
con las 10 entonces lo primero que
podemos preguntarnos es por los valores
extremos de y por aquí voy a marcar el
mínimo de jay y le vamos a llamar a y
por acá arriba tenemos el máximo a este
máximo lo voy a poner por acá y le voy a
llamar ve a una observación olvide darte
la dirección de la trayectoria pero pues
es la misma que antes es decir estamos
recorriendo en el sentido antihorario
misma curva mismo sentido en el vídeo
pasado partimos la curva en dos
funciones de x te acuerdas
es decir tomábamos dos funciones de 1 y
2 que dependían de x ahora lo que
queremos hacer es esto pero al revés en
esta ocasión tenemos que poner a x en
función de y vamos a partir de nuevo la
trayectoria con los puntos extremos
y entonces a la trayectoria de la
izquierda le llamaremos le llamaremos
a ver está verde aquí le vamos a poner
yen no no no mejor vamos a ponerle vamos
a ponerle x es igual no mejor primero le
ponemos el nombre a ver borramos le voy
a poner que ese 2 y ahora sí voy a poner
que está dada por x es igual a x2 de esa
idea y es la segunda trayectoria ahora
va la primera o segunda bueno no importa
puedes empezar donde quieras pero la
primera va a ser esta que está en rosa
mexicano y vamos a ponerle c 1 y que
está dada por x igual a x 1 de que puede
ser un poco confuso cuando estamos
cambiando x y jesse poner a x en función
de y pero otra forma de pensarlo es
girar la cabeza 90 grados y hacer lo
mismo que hacíamos antes sale entonces
realmente no estamos haciendo nada nuevo
sino simplemente copiando la cosa bueno
entonces ahora sí vamos a regresar a las
cuentas siguiendo nuestro dibujo esta
integral de línea de aquí abajo puede
ser descrita y puede ser descrita como
la integral ya no es integral de línea
sino la integral normal
y entonces vamos a ponerse dos primero
vamos a ponerse dos y entonces nos queda
la integral de vea la verdad la
dirección empieza en b y va a de aquí
arriba va bajando bajando y llega a
salir entonces nos queda la integral
debe aa de qué cosa pues q de xy pero ya
sabemos que equivale a algo más verdad
voy a poner así q b y en vez de poner la
x
como te decía x ya está dado en función
de y entonces vamos a escribir aquí x2
déjame ponerlo con color verde x2 deje
coma y aquí vamos a ponerle g
y al final tenemos que poner un de
verdad entonces vamos a poner ve y ok
entonces esta de aquí es la primer mitad
de la integral de línea pero luego
tenemos que sumar lo que corresponde a
la integral
y ahora va la segunda curva verdad ahora
base 1 entonces esa se mueve de a ave
muy bien entonces qué cosa tenemos que
poner pues tenemos que poner q de y en
vez de poner x igual a x2 de hecho ahora
es x igual a x 1 de ella estamos
recorriendo la curva rosa mexicano
entonces nos queda x 1 de iu y luego
tenemos que ponerle coma
y al final un del bar entonces podemos
hacer exactamente lo que hicimos en el
vídeo pasado vamos a volver a repetir lo
que dije porque pudo haber sido un poco
confuso primero vamos a intercambiar
esta ya esta vez para que para poner un
signo menos aquí de modo que los límites
de integración coincidan y entonces
podamos juntar las integrales para
entonces ahí va vamos a juntar estas dos
integrales pues tienen los mismos
límites de integración entonces voy a
pasarme aquí al renglón de abajo le
pongo igual a la integral de a a b y
como éste tiene signo más lo voy a poner
primero entonces voy a escribir
de x 1 de mayo y luego tengo que restar
menos regresamos al color verde menos q
evaluado en x 2 dg coma y deje creo que
éste deje mejor lo pongo de color azul
va a ponerle aquí de iu y ponemos un
paréntesis de ahí fíjate el 10 se
distribuyó entre las dos integrales esto
de aquí sigue siendo idéntico a lo que
hicimos vamos a pasar al otro paso es
decir vamos a ponerle la integral de ave
y entonces vamos a ponerlo como una
función evaluada en dos extremos es
decir vamos a ponerle q de x
mayer y vamos a poner la evaluada con
extremo superior e inferior en el
extremo superior tenemos que poner pues
la curva en rosa mexicano entonces es x
es igual a x1 de g y en el límite
inferior debemos poner pues x igual a x2
de ba
ok entonces vamos super bien vamos a
obtener fíjate otra vez para aclarar lo
que hicimos aquí tenemos una cosa que
pasamos a una cosa integral estamos como
que haciendo las cosas al revés de
cuando hacemos la integral normalmente
simplemente estamos usando la notación
de evaluar en un límite superior y en un
límite inferior aquí voy a poner el de
iu y entonces ahora déjame enmarcar esta
expresión en naranja de hecho sabes que
déjame déjame borrar esto para pasar el
d llegó un poco más a la derecha
entonces voy a poner el d de este lado y
ahora sí con color naranja voy a
encerrar esta expresión
este es el paso pues por así decirlo
clave está esta expresión de naranja la
vamos a reescribir ahora como una
integral vamos a suponer que la parcial
con respecto a q de x existen vamos a
poner aquí como límite inferior x mejor
vamos a decir con el color verde x2 de
iu y en el límite superior vamos a
ponerle x 1 de iu y que tenemos que
poner adentro a pues tenemos que poner
la parcial de q haber ahí va vamos a
ponerlo con este otro color vamos a
poner la parcial de q con respecto a
quién es con respecto a x verdad ahora
es la que se mueve de x esta expresión
que está en el cuadro naranja
es lo mismo que la expresión de aquí
abajo simplemente lo que estamos
haciendo es encontrar el interior de una
integral doble lo de afuera es la
integral de ave bella pero una vez más
para dejar muy claro que estamos
haciendo pues fíjate piensa como si
resolviera esta integral doble lo
primero que tenemos que hacer es anti
derivar de q de x con respecto a x pero
la anti derivada de la parcial de q con
respecto a x con respecto a x escudé xy
entonces ahora ya podemos simplemente
pues poner en los extremos de los
valores x 1 de ella y restar de ahí x 2
dg y regresamos a esta expresión
anterior
creo que esto ya lo deja un poco más
claro verdad con esto ya vamos a obtener
nuestro resultado vamos a ver arriba
para encontrar la interpretación
geométrica de esta integral vamos a ver
qué representa a ver entonces cómo le
hacemos va vamos a pensar de q de x como
la una función de xy entonces vamos a
dibujar otra vez el eje y el eje x y
vamos a meterle tres de poniendo el eje
z esta de aquí es una función que
depende
x y dejé entonces ésta determina una
superficie por aquí más o menos déjame
llamarle a esta la parcial de q con
respecto a x muy bien y lo que está
integral doble nos representa es una
integral en una región r y este x de
jenson de a para entonces la región a la
cual nos estamos refiriendo es en la que
x se mueve entre estas dos funciones y
ya se mueve de a a b verdad entonces ahí
va vamos a poner esta cosa de este
estilo esa de ahí es x s es x 2 de
verdad la verde va y las superiores x 1
de ella la que está en rosa mexicano la
voy a copiar por aquí abajo nos queda
una cosa de este estilo y entonces esas
son las dos curvas que delimitan la
región r
entonces qué estamos haciendo con esta
integral doble lo que hace está
integrada el doble es ir moviendo los
valores de xy dentro de la región dentro
de la región que queda encerrada en las
dos curvas
entonces eso está súper padre otra vez
estamos pasando nuestra integral de
línea aquí a una integral en una región
acotada por justo la línea que está
encerrando la región nos queda algo de
este estilo como un cilindro acotado
entre el plano xy la superficie es un
resultado idéntico al que obtuvimos en
el vídeo pasado eso está muy padre así
de repente fíjate q de x a bava vamos a
dibujar ahora el campo vectorial el
campo vectorial ahora es vertical verdad
tenemos flechas para arriba y para abajo
pero únicamente tienen un componente j
ok voy a poner unas pocas fechas más ok
entonces qué pasa si empezamos con un
campo vectorial que tiene puras flechas
verticales y tomamos una integral de
línea en este campo vectorial nos queda
que la integral de q punto de r es igual
a la integral sobre la curva cerrada de
q mayúscula de xy de g y con lo que
argumentamos eso de ahí es igual a qué
cosa pues a una doble integral a la
doble integral sobre la región r que
encierra la curva eso está súper padre
verdad es la región r que encierra la
curva que corresponde a la integral de
línea entonces va fíjate va de esta a
esta función y la ye se va de ave
entonces eso es justo la integral en la
región que queríamos la región r de qué
cosa pues de la parcial de q con
respecto a x y luego le ponemos pues de
x dgp o lo que queramos pero le voy a
poner mejor vea
muy bien ok entonces fíjate qué es lo
que sigue ya tenemos dos resultados uno
del vídeo pasado y otro el de esther
este vídeo entonces vamos a ver el
resultado del vídeo pasado para ver cómo
lo podemos combinar con este vídeo de
aquí fíjate este es el resultado
anterior ok déjame copiar y pegar los
dos resultados el del vídeo anterior y
el de este para tener más espacio para
hablar de lo que encontramos entonces
esto de aquí lo voy a copiar lo voy a
pegar para pasarlo por aquí abajo y
entonces esto se va a poner emocionante
no parpadea ni un ratito vamos a tomar
también este otro resultado vamos a
darle copiar entonces ahora déjame bajar
aquí le voy a poner pegar
ok entonces estos de acá son los dos
resultados que obtuvimos vamos a pensar
ahora en un campo vectorial arbitrario
es decir ahora si le vamos a permitir
que tenga entradas en jota y entrada se
me va entonces vamos a llamarle efe de
xy y vamos a suponer como dije que tiene
pues una entrada p de xy para el vector
y luego tiene q de xy para el vector j
va entonces
efe es pues pues cualquier campo
vectorial simplemente es una combinación
del pp que hicimos en el vídeo pasado y
que hicimos en este vídeo entonces lo
bonito es que combinando los resultados
de los dos vídeos vamos a poder trabajar
con un campo vectorial arbitrario
entonces vamos a tomar ahora la integral
de línea en una curva pues vamos a poner
digamos la misma curva con la que hemos
estado trabajando una cosa de este
estilo y entonces vamos a ponerle a esta
curva c ok vamos a poner la que va en
sentido antihorario
ok y entonces lo que me interesa es cuál
es la integral de línea sobre c de f
punto de r
ya vimos muchas veces que es de r pero
lo voy a volver a poner de r es igual a
b x por i + d i por j ok entonces esta
integral de línea puede ser descrita
como la integral sobre c la integral de
línea y ahora vamos a poner quienes efe
vamos a poner este sumando por éste
entonces nos queda pd xy por de x
haciendo el producto punto más
este término q de x por d
ok entonces esta cosa de aquí es lo
mismo que la siguiente integral vamos a
abrirla en dos sumas la integral sobre
la curva cdp de xy de x y luego sumarle
la integral de línea de q de xy de g y
mira qué sorpresa justo estas cosas son
las cosas con las cuales estuvimos
trabajando en los dos vídeos anteriores
esta expresión de aquí podemos ponerla
como estar acá arriba es decir vamos a
ponerle igual a la integral doble sobre
la región r
la región r que encierra la curva que se
está de acá de menos la parcial de p con
respecto al menos la parcial de p con
respecto a iu
y en vez de poner de aiete x voy a poner
simplemente un día va y luego podemos
sumarle esta otra integral aquí tenemos
una q y justo lo que probamos en este
segundo vídeo es que eso también podemos
cambiarlo por otra integral doble
entonces vamos a hacer eso acá vamos a
poner la doble integral sobre la misma
región de la parcial de q con respecto a
x b
esto está muy muy bueno fíjate ahora ya
logramos cambiar nuestra integral de
línea de un campo vectorial arbitrario a
una integral doble vamos a juntar esta
estas dos integrales para llegar a la
gran conclusión nos queda nos queda la
doble integral sobre la región r de la
derivada parcial de q con respecto a x
la puse primero porque es positiva luego
hay que restar la parcial de p con
respecto a y
y todo eso de ahí
ok esto está muy padre este es nuestro
gran resultado del vídeo
entonces la integral de línea sobre c de
f punto de r lo podemos cambiar por la
integral doble de esta expresión de aquí
que está súper padre que depende
únicamente de las parciales de las
funciones que están asociadas con el
campo vectorial con respecto a y con
respecto a jota entonces esto de aquí
está muy muy muy bonito
vale entonces fíjate este resultado de
aquí tiene un nombre especial voy a
ponerlo en color verde entonces este
aquí es el teorema de green
muy bien teorema de green bay entonces
este de aquí es una forma muy elegante
de relacionar la integral de línea de un
campo vectorial que tiene estas
derivadas parciales suponiendo que las
tiene con una integral doble en la
región que encierra la curva de la
integral de línea va ahora vamos a un
comentario lateral vamos a recordar que
hace algunos vídeos vimos un resultado
para campos vectoriales conservativos
éste decía que sí efe es conservativo lo
cual recordemos que quiere decir que es
el gradiente de una función escalar
entonces jefe es conservativa la
integral de línea de en cualquier curva
cerrada y es igual a cero como podemos
combinar esto con el teorema de grimm
pues esto nos dice que si f conservativo
este término debe de ser igual a 0
porque porque esta es la única forma en
la cual podemos asegurar que la doble
integral va a ser cero sin importar en
qué regiones estemos integrando esto
requiere pensarlo un poquito para ver
que la parte fuerte de la afirmación
está en que pasa para todas todas las
regiones r
de esta forma concluimos lo siguiente
concluimos que la parcial de q
respecto a x menos la parcial de p con
respecto a y es igual a cero o
reescribiendo un poco más bonito estas
dos expresiones deben de ser iguales es
decir que la parcial de q con respecto a
x es igual a la parcial de p con
respecto a y con esto obtenemos un
bonito corolario del teorema de y bueno
cuando estudies ecuaciones exactas en
ecuaciones diferenciales vas a ver esta
expresión a cada rato no me quiero meter
mucho en detalles pero en el fondo los
campos conservativos están íntimamente
relacionados con una ecuación
diferencial exacta pero bueno mejor no
nos metamos en intimidades por ahora lo
que haremos en los siguientes vídeos es
tomar esta super herramienta que
acabamos de descubrir esta de acá y
vamos a aplicar algunos problemas
concretos para fijar mejor las ideas nos
vemos pronto